THE TOUGH START FOR OTTAWA.
PART OF TME BACA
POWE KAKKO, NUMBER 34, WHO'S
MISSED THE LAST 71
THE QUICK SHOT. CASS LICK
IS IN THE
LINDBERG MOVES IT UP.
DRYDEN HUNT PLAYS IT BA
ZIBANEJAD, KAKKO, AND VATRANO.T
SEVEN BLOCKED 'S BEEN SHARP IN .
RANGERS HAVE HAD A LOT OF
NIGHT.
AND HE SCORES!
RIGHT THERE IN GAMEB DOES.
LIFTS THE STICK OF
THE OTHER TWO CAME FROM DEFENSE.
HERE'S THE ATTEMPTED -- THE  IN.
FANS ON THE SHOT.
THE AGGRESSIVELY.
GETS IT BACK TO KREIDER, AND
THERE'S THE OPPORTUNITY.
ONE MORE.
THIS IS CLEARED ASIDE AND UP THE
SCORE!TOPS HIM THERE, AND THE
RANGERS GO BACK TO WORK DOWN TH
ASSIST NOW HAS 87 POINTS ON T
NUMBER 48CK, ZIBANEJAD WITH THE.
LOOKED UP AND  LEAVES IT
FOR LINDGREN.
>> Joe: YEAH.THE BOARDS
SAM -- I MEAN PANARIN IS JUST --
HE'S DANCING.G.PABOARDS.
TKACHUK PLAYING IT
THERE.
CHRIS CHARACTERIZER, WITHNIPEG
NIGHT IN OTTAWA AS THEY PLAY
HE PLAY.
GOOD PLAY TO THE FRONT GOES THRH
AS MILLER CHECKED KELLY.
AND THE QUICK RELEASE.